[Applause]
Coran got that Rozier explodes to the
rim sits a db2 three control
[Applause]
because the speed and pace that Marant
is able to play at draw us for defenders
and the kick to the corner has been the
Grizzlies Brandon Clark boards the
Rozier mystery look at this is a Moran
fast break and you can see once he
crossed half court and saw that the
Hornets were not hustling back
defensively while he pushed it into
another gear you can see only lap now
gone then once he back to that point
there was no Clark real jinja's 12
rebounds 12 and 12
marenick spoke to the cuts and finishes
saij within two morant in double figures
he's got ten to go along with five
assists
of this third quarter as well as they
started Marant Clark panic move against
Rozier to get the finish Michigan State
teammates gorge dribbled will see he'll
get the backdoor
watch the fake bow doesn't go too far
keeps it to himself and then they can
going to the bass you see oops not going
to you and then gsella with the wrap
around the waist you see the right hand
there Memphis it's forever look at the
speed
give something accomplished look at this
regard he's coming down he is beyond the
basket would've body [ __ ] is still able
to contort my goodness he's beyond at
the left hand and Crowder boards oh nice
pass and Clark with a finish off the
beautiful set up by Jamar and Moran
averaging seven points seven assists in
the preseason
only James Hart is averaging more Mills
Gabe Belinelli and hurtle that passed
too tall for him San Antonio the
turnover Moran gets to the rim flips it
up a knee in off the window JAMA ran
first azita Dryden quickness here
catches the defender back on his heels
able to finish with the right hand no
rant oh what a pass Clark with the
finish and the foul oh what a beautiful
drop off by Moran I was in the first
quarter it would make a beautiful pass
in a tight space Clark knows what to do
with it after that he'll imports found
the shots that really ignited this team
offensively but they made the stop to
give him the opportunity Moran with the
hesitation move scopes and scores but
early Crowder may not be making shots in
his game but coming up with steals and
big Tyler rebound he's got 10 Jaron
powers it down right on the top of
deshante Murray Grizzlies with 28 paint
points timeout on the floor
Jackson the slam the Grizzlies within
four
on the game 55:49 cause he's got within
one Spurs with a nifty response hand for
ant over the top there's a nice backdoor
cut and then takes off with the two-hand
slam nice pass there by Jaron mmm
precisely if you don't come to finish
something goes wrong he still makes it
right yes yes weatherspoon stripped Jae
Crowder with the takeaway timeout san
antonio 14 little eye contact and let
the young fella go and throw it down
beat yourself up in the face here part
of that don't
[Laughter]
I'm gonna power it through and point
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content